[MUSIC]
Hi, thank you so much for having me here
such a good way of getting people from
different disciplines especially
I'm from social sciences.
To kind of talk about very
important issues facing our
society and how we can use
interdisciplinary methods to
kind of mitigate those issues.
So just a little background
on me before I start my
presentation.
So as I said earlier, my name's
Anamika Barman-Adhikari, and
I'm an assistant professor in
the School of Social Work at
the University of Denver.
And in terms of my
research interest,
I'm fascinated with the idea
of social influence.
And for the last eight years, I
have been trying to understand,
kind of why people cluster
in social networks,
both face-to-face and online.
And kind of the psychological,
sociological, cognitive,
and mathematical rules
that govern how these
networks tend to operate.
In terms of my talk today, I
have to add one caveat before I
even get into the presentation.
I am not an AI expert.
I'm a social scientist
who has come to value and
appreciate how AI can be used
in the public health domain.
And I'm gonna use one of our
projects which is known as GUIDE
to kind of showcase how
interdisciplinary research,
especially AI in
public health and
social work had come together
to solve a very important issue
in the domain of
behavioral sciences and
specially substance
abuse prevention.
So as I said earlier,
I'm gonna talk about GUIDE
which is an acronym,
which stands for Group-based
Intervention Decision Aid for
Substance Abuse Prevention
among Homeless Youth.
But before I get into that,
I think it would be useful to
get a sense of the scope of
substance abuse and homelessness
among youth who have
experienced homelessness
in the United States.
So in terms of the population
and numbers, approximately 1.5
million youth are homeless in
the US at any given point of
the year, which might be
surprising to a lot of you here,
because the US is one of the
richest countries in the world,
but we still have stark
levels of inequality.
In terms of the rates of
substance use among homeless
youth, there's so many things
that plague you to experience
homelessness, but substance
abuse is especially problematic.
So based on data collected
in between 2011 to 2013 in
Los Angeles from
a thousand homeless youth.
What we found is that about
a quarter of youth engage in
either meth use or prescription
drug misuse and about 15%,
13% to 15%, engage in heroin or
injection drug use.
And to put these numbers into
context why this is problematic,
approximately 1% of youth,
equivalently aged youth,
in the US who are housed and
not homeless engage in the same
kind of drug use rates.
So 1% versus 25%,
that's pretty stark.
So one of the reasons why I'm so
interested in substance abuse is
because it is a network
based phenomenon.
So social influence is key
to understanding why people
engage in drug abuse.
So this is a network map and
what you see here is 160
homeless youth who are connected
to each other in a social space.
And the blue dots are people,
all of the dots are people and
the lines are basically
the relationships among them.
And the blue nodes
are people who engage,
youth who engage in drug use.
And the grey and
white dots are people who
don't engage in drug use.
And what you'll
see here is that,
really drug use is a public
health phenomenon, right?
All the drug users tend
to cluster together,
which is explained by
classic social theories.
Homophily, the notion that
birds of the same
feather flock together.
And also social learning theory,
if you're around people
who engage in a behavior,
guess what, you're more likely
to engage in that behavior.
So, however, the ironic thing is
that in terms of preventing drug
use, even though networks
are implicated in how,
why substance abuse happens.
Networks are also the key
to preventing drug abuse.
So what research has found that
prevention programs are most
effective when they
have a peer component,
because then people get to
engage in drug refusal skills or
drug resistance skills in their
natural peer environment.
So the way these peer network
interventions have been designed
is that people are usually
assigned to groups based on
random assignment without
any knowledge of how they
are connecting to their peers.
Or also, not an understanding
of the social space
where they're
engaging in drug use.
Or the other method that is used
is that youth get to choose
their own peer groups.
And if you go back to
the previous slide,
what we saw is that peers tend
to hang out with other peers
who are like themselves.
So a lot of times what happens
is that a lot of users come to
get together and that increases
their drug use behavior which is
known by the term called
Deviancy Training.
And Deviancy Training is
a problem in prevention science.
It has been a sticky problem in
prevention science ever since we
have been trying to prevent drug
abuse among any groups of youth.
So in terms of the question we
wanted to address or the problem
we wanted to address through our
interdisciplinary collaboration
is, how to assign people to
groups based on their existing
network relationships, and also
their substance use behaviors.
And the way we saw how AI
helped is that with AI,
we wanted to understand whether
we could have a predictive
algorithm that could tell us
whether or not if we engage in
that intervention, if Deviancy
Training would be exacerbated.
Or if you could really
use Deviancy Training.
So in the context of AI,
we really saw this as
a graph partitioning problem.
So if you go back to the figure
that I showed you earlier,
what if we could
design an algorithm
that could reconfigure
this network
based on drug use as well as
preexisting relationships,
in a way where we could
optimize positive influence.
So instead of cutting these
networks into clusters,
we had to reconfigure people in
a way that we could basically
reduce the problem of
deviancy training.
So in order to do that,
we thought we had to model three
important parameters, and I'm
gonna talk about what parameters
we included and not really
the simulation techniques,
and Phoebe's gonna
address that in her doc.
But in terms of understanding
why Deviancy Training happens
and how to mitigate it,
we thought there are three
important modeling components
that we needed to include
in our algorithm.
First, is Network Influence
which I'm gonna talk about.
The second,
is Network Dynamic Modeling and
third is
Interventionist Modeling.
So in terms of Influence
Modeling, as Amalia was saying
earlier, there are competing
influences in that perks there.
People are associated
with a lot of people and
because of the diversity of
these influences they are both
positive and
negative influences on people.
So the way we saw it is that,
it is linear threshold model.
So basically people
get both positive and
negative influences
from their peers, and
if the influence signal
crosses the threshold value,
then the person is more likely
to change their behavior.
So for example, if a user is
connected to more non-users
than users, they're more likely
to change their behavior.
Also, because this intervention
the way we design social work
intervention is that it happens
over a period of time, and
over that period of time people
change their behaviors and
also their relationships.
It was important for us to model
how those relationships change.
And what we hypothesized is that
if a user became a non-user,
they're probably more
likely to strengthen their
relationships with
other non-users and
weaken their relationships
with other users.
And that's something we
also wanted to model
in the algorithm.
Also there is the
interventionist components in
social work.
Usually, interventions are
delivered by professionals, and
they are also a key component
of the intervention.
And we wanted to basically
understand what kind of
relationships the participants
have with the interventionist,
and how that changes the nature
of their behaviors as well as
their networks.
In terms of the results, what we
found is that GUIDE outperforms
the traditional status quo
methods of random assignment,
and peer chosen
groups by almost 40%.
That's pretty huge, and
that's statistically and
practically meaningful.
And what this emphasis is that
it's important to acknowledge
existing relationships and
network tie strength and
behavior in understanding how we
can minimize Deviancy Training.
How GUIDE helps?
In the real world, we are
planning to deploy this decision
aid in a shelter in Denver,
Colorado, and what we'll be able
to do is to predict scenarios
where Deviancy Training is
increased thus, saving time,
money, and effort.
Future strategies, real world
deployment that I talked about.
We also need to make certain
tweaks to our model to
kind of include
uncertainties and
we also need to make our
model a little more complex,
because right now, we are just
modelling three things.
We hope to model other
behavioral parameters, and
demographic variables that might
also impact substance abuse.
So that concludes
my presentation.
I'll be happy to talk
to you later and
answer any questions
you have right now.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yes.
>> In homelessness and
drug abuse.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Which peers does?
>> So that's a great question.
So substance abuse happens prior
to people becoming homeless, and
it could be a cause of
homelessness as well.
So a lot of people
become homeless,
because they're
substance users and
also because they have to
survive in an environment
where drug abuse is considered
to be a survival skill.
It could get exacerbated because
of the circumstances they face
after they experience
homelessness.
So it could be both.
It's a chicken and egg thing.